[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 19e
jour de guerre en ukraine l'étau se
resserre autour de kiev au moins une
personne a été tuée dans des
bombardements russes sur la capitale qui
ont visé un immeuble résidentiel et l'
usine aéronautique antonoff selon la
mairie de la capitale ukrainienne
l'armée russe n'exclut pas de prendre le
contrôle total des grandes villes
ukrainiennes de nombreux centres urbains
sont d'ailleurs encerclé la russie a
demandé l'aide économique et militaire
de la chine selon le new york times
alors que washington a mis en garde
pékin contre toute assistance à moscou
une information d'ailleurs démenties par
les russes le chef de la diplomatie
européenne a affirmé à confirmer en tout
cas qu'un quatrième train de sanctions
contre moscou était en passe d'être
adopté à bruxelles alors vladimir
poutine va-t-il gagner la guerre quels
sont les risques d'embrasement comment
finalement la guerre en ukraine
bouleverse tel l'ordre mondial on en
parle avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés le général jean
claude allard bonsoir à vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris bienvenue
dans le débat en face de vous rani
daubenton bonsoir journaliste essayiste
auteur de l'ukraine l'indépendance à
tout prix et c'est aux éditions buchet
chastel baisse bienvenue à vous
également avec nous également des
chenaux benoît bonsoir vous êtes
correspondante défense à la fp
présidente de l'association des
journalistes de défense bienvenus en
face de vous pierre conessa essayiste et
ancien haut fonctionnaire du ministère
de la défense bonsoir également à vous
avant de démarrer cette discussion on va
écouter quelques habitants dans la ville
de kiev vous allez voir qu'ils prennent
les armes
j'étais agriculteur avant l'invasion
russe et j'ai l'intention de retourner
directement combat les russes ne
prendront pas kiev nous sommes prêts à
nous battre jusqu'à la victoire
chaque maison chaque hall d'entrée
chaque sous sol sera un obstacle
une embuscade pour eux qui elle sera
leur cimetière
qui a seule chose qu'ils vont gagner
mais on va tout de suite aller à kiev
retrouver dans ce renvoi est spécial
vous allez voir qu'il s'est rendu
johnatan wolfe devant cet immeuble qui a
été détruit ce matin par un bombardement
c'était au nord de la capitale on
regarde vous pouvez voir derrière moi la
façade de cet immeuble qui a été
complètement détruite par par
l'explosion d'un missile qui a qui a
atterri ici ce matin à 5h une façade qui
a été complètement soufflé il y avait
ici une cage d'escalier qui a été
détruite sur trois ou quatre étages
toute la façade est complètement noirci
et toutes les fenêtres ont été soufflées
les balcons ont été également détruits
nous avons parlé à une jeune habitante
de cet immeuble anastasia qui a eu la
chance de s'en tirer elle nous a raconté
cette scène terrible qu'elle a vécu au
moment où le missile a atterri sur le
bâtiment elle a d'abord entendu le
sifflement du missile qui l'a réveillé
et puis le choc la terre qui tremble et
et tout le monde évidemment complètement
complètement choquée elle était en train
de récupérer des effets personnels comme
beaucoup d'habitants du bâtiment lorsque
nous l'avons rencontré tout à l'heure et
si on peut parfois oublier la guerre
quand on est dans le centre ville de
kiev qui est beaucoup plus calme je peux
vous dire qu'ici la guerre est très
sonore et on entend beaucoup de manière
répétée les tirs d'artillerie a résonné
dans le ciel de kiev général jean claude
allard l'armée russe gagne du terrain on
s'apprête finalement peut-être à
assister au siège de kiev quelle est la
stratégie militaire des russes est ce
que ces dates fixées les villes et côté
on est dans le siège en fait il n'est
pas totalement la ville n'est pas
totalement encerclée
je voudrais remarquer c'est que
aujourd'hui les russes sont arrivés à un
moment où il leur faut s'emparer d'un
certain nombre de villes donc ils vont
faire un choix et
à part les premiers jours ou rentrer
dans kiev s'emparer de palais
présidentiel et d'instituer le
gouvernement c'était efficace
aujourd'hui je ne vois plus tellement le
l'efficacité d'une prise de kiev
ensuite non je pensais qu'ils
renonceraient nombre il y siège il faut
soit dans ciel de la ville soit on
essaie de rentrer dedans alors kiev la
réflexion que je me fais la suivante
c'est que j'ai une ville de deux
millions huit cent mille habitants
aujourd'hui ça ne me paraît plus un
objectif c'est toujours un objectif mais
ça ne me paraît plus parce que j'ai ce
qui a une stature internationale tels
que on peut plus le déboulonner si je
puis dire alors kiev ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que c'est une ville de deux
millions huit cent mille habitants il
faut de l'infanterie faut des chars il
faut énormément de choses les russes les
soviétiques au une expérience d'une
prise de deux millions huit cent mille
habitants c'est berlin en 1945 en 1945
pour contre berlin ils ont rasé la ville
donc peut-être vont-ils rasé kiev mais
je ne sais pas et surtout ils ont eu
cent mille morts et 200 mille blessés je
suis pas sûr que l'armée russe
aujourd'hui soit prête à ça en revanche
il me semble qu'il ya d'autres villes
qui peuvent être des objectifs
stratégiques intéressant et je pense à
mario pour lui mais bon mario pas non
mais oui à marioupol justement qu'ils
seraient là pour le coup elle plus sur
le point de tomber vous pensez alors il
ya cette stratégie d'asphyxié ce n'est
pas celle sur le point de tomber mais ce
que je vois également c'est que les
russes ont besoin d'un succès ils
n'auront pas immédiatement kiev ils
auront plus vraisemblablement mario paul
et surtout que mario paul rentre
également dans les plans du président
poutine c'est à dire qu' il va essayer
d'avoir cette continuité entre le
dombass est la crimée et puis parmi
toutes les raisons qui pousseraient à
mario paul ces cas mario paul il dit il
veut des nazis fier et à marioupol en
avant ce qu'il y à la brigade azoff qui
est le symbole pour lui de la
nazification si je puis dire donc vous
vous rendez compte que s'il arrive à
prendre mario paul il va et il va le
présenter à son peuple comme une
réussite d'un film dont vous êtes
d'accord avec cela veut dire général
jean claude allard et puis finalement
est ce que vous pouvez me décrire un peu
difficultés de l'armée russe parce que
concrètement on voit bien que ce n'est
pas si facile non effectivement l'armée
russe a relativement surpris par des
débuts extrêmement difficile au début de
l'invasion et a eu du mal finalement à
obtenir des gains très rapide escompté
désormais maintenant on voit la
progression de l'armée russe mais qui se
concentre même sur effectivement des
centres urbains qui les encerclent qu'il
assiège et ils essayent effectivement
dans l'est comme disait le général de
prendre marioupol qui effectivement une
un endroit vraiment stratégique parce
que ça permettrait effectivement de
relier les territoires séparatistes
pro-russes du dombass à la péninsule de
crimée qu'ils ont annexé en 2014 donc on
voit bien l'intérêt et c'est d'ailleurs
là que la population souffre le plus
visiblement les russes ont coupé les
réseaux d'électricité d'eau on parle
vraiment de fin et de problèmes de vivre
dans cette population donc voilà mais
pour l'instant on attend un peu de voir
ce qui va se passer je suis d'accord
avec le général les russes maintenant
vraiment besoin de victoire militaire
pour pour finalement les transformer en
gains politiques parce que là ils ont
déçu quelque part et donc ça risque même
de durcir leur position et leur
agressivité quelque part parce que on
voit bien que les bombardements se sont
intensifiés sur plusieurs villes donc
c'est un c'est un signe très à la très
alarmant pour les populations civiles
pierre conesa quelle est la stratégie
finalement que vladimir poutine pour
rebondir justement sur ce que vient de
dire daphné benoit d'après les propos
qui sont relayées par la presse russe a
donc désormais totalement son contrôle
du kremlin poutine planifierait dans une
première étape une épuration voir une
extermination de grande ampleur du
peuple ukrainien
écoutez 1
je sais pas ce que poutine pense j'ai
peut-être la seule personne de tous les
cons des gens qui ont été consultés
jamais avoir rencontré poutine moi ce
qui m'a beaucoup frappé c'est que son
plan de guerre était en fait une
pénétration sur cinq axes de pénétration
différentes donc ce n'était pas un
incident de frontière c'était une
planification d'une espèce de mise à
genoux de l'ukraine moi je temps de
penser dans un premiers temps qu
effectivement la seule destitution du
président pouvait constituer un objectif
mais l'individu s'est montré beaucoup
plus coriace que l'on imaginé
probablement les russes et donc on ne
sait pas quelle est la stratégie on sait
que la guerre entraîne la guerre c'est à
dire que finalement s'il n'a pas assez
succès ça veut dire qu'il risque de
durcir enfin aujourd'hui ça ça veut dire
quoi 2 ça veut dire éventuellement
bombardé plus avoir des méthodes
beaucoup plus brutale et savait l'armée
russe est une armée d'invasion c'est pas
une armée d'occupation donc appartement
où il est obligé de mobiliser du monde
parce que finalement il ya de la
résistance sur des villes même conquise
il est obligé d'augmenter ses effectifs
s'il veut quand même montré je pense que
son objectif un certain moment ça va
être accepté des négociations mais en
position de force alors qu'est ce que
c'est que la position de force militaire
ça va être probablement de tenir un
certain nombre de points stratégiques
dernière remarque ils ont bombardé hier
donc une ville proche de la frontière
polonaise qui était le point d'entrée
des fournitures d'armes fournies par les
occidentaux ça c'est un avertissement
pour nous c'est cet avertissement pour
nous on va d y revenir à nidau bâton est
ce que vladimir poutine souhaite mettre
la main mise sur l'ensemble du
territoire ukrainien ont pas écoutés
qu'il le souhaite une chose qu'il y
arrive c'est tout à fait une autre
histoire d'abord faut dire que les
villes qui sont sous contrôle russe ne
parviennent pas à mobiliser la
population contraire c'est à dire voir
ce qui se passe à kherson on voit ce qui
se passe à rares kif il ya des
manifestations massives en permanence
dans toutes ces villes qui sont sous
soi-disant sous contrôle russe autre
chose qui me paraît important comme vous
l'aviez signaler cette extension du
conflit à l'ouest d'hier elle est
confirmée aujourd'hui par la taxe sur la
télévision deux rives nos rives nos est
également une ville très à l'ouest donc
on a une extension du conflit de ce côté
là qui est effectivement bien sûr un
signal d'alarmé pour mieux ensuite
autres signaux important c'est les
redditions au sein de l'armée russe les
conscrits de crime et refuse de
s'engager
des centaines de marins non on refusait
de débarquer à odessa il y à un certain
nombre de soldats qui ont enregistré des
appels alors savoir si significatif dans
écoutez c'est significatif ça c'est vous
qui est employé ce terme aux accusations
sur celles à long terme bon ce sont des
signaux importants dire qu'ils sont
massifs et que c'est avec ça qu'on
pourra faire reculer cette stratégie
globale pour l'instant on peut pas le
dire mais ce sont des des signaux très
important général jean claude allard
justement pour cette ce combat qui gagne
l'ouest du pays ces frappes hier soir
dont je le rappelle c'était sur la base
militaire de yaro vif proche de la
pologne finalement est-ce que ça change
vraiment la donne est-ce que les risques
c est un effet domino est ce que l'otan
va devoir changer de stratégie est ce
qu'un risque d'embrasement simplement
non je voulais simplement dire une chose
que pour cette extension de combats à
l'ouest
c'est le b à ba de l'école de guerre ça
veut dire c'est ce qu'on appelle une
couverture donc soit l'ennemi risque de
nous attaquer par derrière il faut
mettre des forces soient simplement ils
risquent d'amener des des armes comme
c'est le cas et moi je suis étonné que
il n'est pas entrepris quelque chose
avance et tout parce que c'est le béa là
ils se sont couverts de deux façons dès
le début du conflit le dimanche 27 je
crois en annonçant la mise en alerte de
leur force de dissuasion ça veut dire
que ils ont ils ont attaqué sur sa
direction comme des pierres connaisseurs
et la sixième c'est la frontière elle
est tenue par la menace nucléaire donc
c'est pour ça que l'otan ne rentre pas
pendant que la frontière de la frontière
de la frontière de l'otan on sort atroce
justement avec athènes un bar de man oui
mais en ces îles il est toujours il est
toujours une crête et comme je vous dis
c'est le b à ba après il faut ce qu'il
faut essayer ce qu'il fallait essayer
pour lui c'est pour ces généraux de ces
deux couper tout approvisionnement voilà
donc moi ça me paraît ne voyait pas une
provocation supplémentaire
bon oui certainement mais en même temps
c'est le b à ba la maison indiquée par
le kremlin comme une provocation
supplémentaire et comme les avancées
supplémentaires voilà mais après vous
avez les deux choses derrière après vous
vous appliquez ça et puis vous avez tout
le discours pour faire monter en
puissance pour faire peur mais et c'est
évident que
voilà c'est il faut se couvrir comme
l'on dit en termes militaires voilà je
comprends bien ce que je veux dire c'est
d'ailleurs empêché que en alimente
j'observe une chose c'est que
lorsque l'armée russe a débarqué en
syrie à damas la première chose qu'elle
a faite on a dit oui vont attaquer à
l'aide des touches en fait elle est
montée le long de la frontière
syro turque pour couper les
approvisionnements les convois qui
sortait et les convois d'armes qui
rentre et voilà c'est bien là le chemin
même schéma qu'en séries alors justement
ce qui peut utiliser l'armé chimique à
réunir poutine d'un autre c'est un autre
débat mais je m'attends ça fait loin
parce que tout à parle de la série oui
mais je voulais juste revenir très
rapidement sur cette histoire de
bombardements à l'ouest c'est
véritablement comme vous l'avez dit un
avertissement adressé à l'otan et c'est
une très mauvaise nouvelle aussi pour
pour les l'armée ukrainienne si jamais
ces interventions russes finissent par
vraiment appauvrir ces voies
d'approvisionnement des armes que nous
nous efforçons de d'envoyer vers vers
les ukrainiens des armes antichars des
armes anti aériennes c'est un problème
c'est également dans cette localité qui
était un centre d'entraînement que que
se sont concentrées les forces
étrangères qui viennent en aide des
forces l'ukrainienne donc vraiment
c'était quand même un symbole important
mais après effectivement avec une prise
de risques on a faim il doit être
envoyé 20 km d'un pays européen est
effectivement 20 kilomètres de la
frontière de l'otan donc c'est on n'est
pas à l'abri
d'une erreur de calcul
un missile qui passe de l'autre côté de
la frontière il faut être très prudent
effectivement d'autant que comme le
disait le chef d'état major des armées
dans une lettre cette semaine la semaine
dernière là justement ce manque de
victoires pour l'instant par vladimir
poutine le rend d'autant plus
imprévisible et ça je crois que c'est
très important de le préciser pierre
connais ça oui je crois qu'il faut quand
même garder à l'esprit que l'ukraine ce
qui est plus grand que la france c'est à
dire que même si demain tomber la ville
de nantes vous voulez ça veut pas dire
que l'ensemble des frontières françaises
très fermé vous rendez compte que là si
on a cette frontière de l'ue crème avec
l'ensemble des pays de l'otan s'il
voulait construire l'équivalent de ce
qu'a été la île maurice par exemple ce
que vous rappelez vous pour l'algérie il
faudrait des années et puis beaucoup
d'hommes mobilisés pour empêcher tout un
provisionnement donc là le signal il est
effectivement destiné aux pays de l'otan
qui sont toujours à s'interroger sur la
stratégie à adopter
cette stratégie reconnaissance donc ça
veut dire quoi article 5 ça veut dire
qu'effectivement si jamais il y avait un
missile qui tombait de l'autre côté donc
à 30km côté polonais l'article 5 et
déclencher non l'article 5 il faut pas
lui faire dire ce qu'il veut pas dire
l'article 5 est un engagement de
consultation en cas de conflit pour l'un
des pays membres peut pas dire que c'est
une engagement automatique rappelez-vous
donc ça c'est quand même quelque chose
qui me laisse quand même une espèce de
marge de manoeuvre vous convaincrez pas
tout à coup les espagnols les italiens
qu'il faut absolument déclencher des
années le menton oui je voudrais juste
parce qu on a parlé beaucoup de
militaires et à juste raison et je
voudrais juste signaler que pour
l'instant il ya plus de morts civiles
cudmore militaire
du côté ukrainien et que apparemment les
attaques et la stratégie dans la mesure
où la défense ukrainienne quand même
s'avère assez coriace si je puis dire
c'est que de faire le maximum de pertes
du côté civil et on l'a vu pas seulement
à marioupol arar kiffa kherson on l'a vu
dans la plupart des villes attaquées on
attaque les hôpitaux les écoles et tous
les centres stratégiques importants et
on l'a vu également c'est un point
également qu'il est loin d'être
négligeable avec tchernobyl
will come here commencé à voir des
problèmes également un port gier c'est à
dire cette donne nucléaire
r est également reste également dans le
chantier si je puis dire dans le
chantier pour une sorte de guerre
psychologique où effectivement c'est ça
se joue avec le feu on joue avec le feu
vous êtes d'accord général jean claude
allard juste pour revenir seulement sa
stratégie de l'otan sur l'article 5 est
ce que ça veut dire que il y aura une
riposte américaine si un missile tombe
est effectivement du côté polonais cette
fois et côté je voulais souligner que
dès
les premiers jours du conflit je crois
le deuxième ou le troisième les
présidents américain et russe ont donné
leur aval où ont poussé à la création
d'une cellule de
coordination entre les russes et les
américains de façon à gérer toute
interférence aux autres ils avaient fait
la même chose encore une fois également
en syrie de façon à ce que les deux
grandes puissances ne se trouve pas
entraîner dans un conflit pour quelque
chose de pour un accrochage alors là il
pensait certainement pas à ce qu'on voit
actuellement mais il pensait à l'espace
et internationales et aux mères
international où les bâtiments
américains et russes les avions
américains et russes vol en permanence
parfois ça interpelle parfois que vaut
le quota cote donc il ne fallait pas
pousser je rappelle également que notre
notre président de la république à faire
message aux armées dans lequel il dit un
peu implicitement pour explicitement
pour les armées parce qu'ils savent
décrypter le langage est implicitement
pour le grand public là il fallait faire
très attention c'est à dire qu'il peut
contrer justement cet accord dont vous
parlez la prévisibilité de blaye le
maire d'ercis c'est à dire que le lot
tomassi et l'automaticité ne se fera
qu'après des discussions donc entre les
alliés et puis avec le avec poutine
peu de risques d'embrasement
être personnel je ne vois pas la russie
déjà copieusement engagé en ukraine sur
plusieurs fronts
simultanés
provoquer enfin un affrontement avec
avec les forces de l'otan qui sont comme
vraiment supérieure à celle du risque
donc je pense pas qu'on irait jusque-là
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est que
on va vers visiblement un durcissement
du conflit et malheureusement au
détriment des civils qui vont qui vont
énormément souffrir jeu ça veut dire la
moldavie peut-être puisqu'elle ne fait
pas partie de l'otan puisque la
transnistrie en istrie effectivement il
ya déjà des forces russes qui sont
présentes déployés en transnistrie donc
effectivement ça on ne peut pas
l'exclure mais je pense que le là aussi
est très occupée déjà sur le front est
de l'ukraine et qu'elle doit vraiment
transformer l'essai pour une fois encore
obtenir des gains est à cet égard et ils
vont rapidement avoir un problème de
masse de régénération de leurs forces
sur le terrain on le voit la dirm hier
poutine a donné son accord pour pour
appeler en renfort
des milliers de combattants syrien donc
ça c'est intéressant parce que ils ont
ils ont vraiment besoin de mobiliser de
plus en plus de force sur ce terrain
voulait réagir et jean-claude l arrivée
non mais c'est tout à fait ça je
rajouterai qu on peut imaginer non pas
un embrasement mais une tentative de
déstabilisation ailleurs dans le monde
le mali comme comme poutine l'a fait
lorsqu'il a voulu dire mais moi aussi
j'existe donc le mali la centrafrique or
là il est en train d'examiner le rappel
de ses combattants il est en train de
faire revenir des combattant de géorgie
et d'une marque haut-karabakh on peut
pas d'un corner car tout le monde a
compris et est également regardé des
bataillons qui viennent du pacifique
donc il peut pas se permettre de
d'embraser essais pour chaque
effectivement on peut remarquer que tiré
à 20 kilomètres des frontières c'est
c'est un peu risqué c'est un peu risqué
mais ça resterait à l'erreur de décret
en ce sens que ces missiles de croisière
voilà qui reconnaissent à vous êtes
d'accord oui mais même si vous voulez
vous avez utilisé le terme
d'imprévisibilité de poutine
et surtout maintenant vous allez
remarquer qu'on psychanalyse poutine
vous avez des pape sy qui aboutissent
sur la question les plateaux télé vous
dire que je n'ai jamais rencontré mais
je peux vous dire qu'il est comme ça qu
il est comme ça
l'adisq on parle de couture isolement
par beaucoup de sa paranoïa d'ailleurs
même et belle macro et enfin aussi j'en
sais rien mais enfin cela dit ça me
paraît un chef d'état qui s'ils
voulaient à une certaine conscience des
intérêts de son pays est effectivement
voyez une chose qui me fascine beaucoup
c'est que il décide d'avoir lire
l'ukraine pour soi disant pour protéger
les populations du donbass or il existe
en droit international la responsabilité
de protéger donc sur lequel il aurait
très bien pu s'appuyer en disant je
viens protéger des populations russe
c'est ce qu'on a fait en libye on dire
hors protège les populations or c'est
pas ça qui l'a utilisé il a tout de
suite utiliser la guerre ça veut bien
dire qu'il a quelque chose en tête qui
est quand même cette position de force
qui peut-être l'occupation totale de
l'ukraine je n'en sais rien mais en tout
cas il n'a pas l'intention d'arrêter le
processus donc on peut toujours faire
semblant de faire des négociations mais
ça portera sur des couloirs humanitaires
donc peut-être occupation totale de
l'ukraine on peut quand même penser ce
que vous dites à nu devant ton si si si
les ukrainiens résiste pas trop oui oui
ce qui est frappant tout casser dans la
stratégie c'est ce mélange d'art mais de
nature différente si je puis dire saisir
on a à la fois des mercenaires ces gens
qui vont venir du moyen-orient on a les
gens de kadirov on a des conscrits parce
que maintenant le kremlin avait affirmé
qu'il n'y avait pas de conscrits
maintenant tous les conscrits déclare à
voix haute que bon ils ont été trompés
on a les gens de wagner et donc on a là
un mélange
qui sur le terrain alors je sais pas
parce que là c'est des questions
d'experts pour lequel je n'ai pas
d'habilitation particulière mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que sur le terrain on voit
que les conscrits sont mis en avant un
peu comme chair à canon poussé par soit
des mercenaires soit des armées
régulières soit et c est que tout ça
provoque des difficultés aussi dans les
avancements je ne sais pas ça si si on
peut stratégiquement analyser cette
situation
mais ce mélange de combattants de nature
différente faut on peut dire vraiment
directement de tueurs et d'autres côtés
de conscrits qui sont plutôt des otages
dans cette situation donne un aspect
très hétérodoxes cette situation
générale jean claude allaire vous
confirmer sa oui bien sûr les troupes
sur le terrain sont sont très variés les
l'important c'est des deux côtés
d'ailleurs il ya une armée régulière
chez les ukrainiens une garde nationale
et puis la population qui s'y met donc
et chez les russes aussi il ya des des
soldats d'origine différente donc il
faut les il faut les former et les faire
travailler ensemble et donc cette
seconde une ex en termes d'efficacité
militaire sûr de sûr bien sûr c'est
beaucoup plus complexe sur les sur les
sur les objectifs de poutine moi je
serai
enfin moi je lis qu'il ai dit écoute ce
qu'il dit et je sais que c'est ça c'est
objectif pour moi y'a pas de soucis et à
prendre l'ensemble de l'ukraine pas ben
il dit un excellent il est alors là je
délire il veut un statut neutre et
dénucléarisé pour l'ukraine
démilitarisation obligatoire
dénazification
reconnaissance de la delà de l'autorité
de la russie axée sur la crimée les deux
républiques
souveraines les deux républiques dans le
donbass et dans leurs limites voilà je
je crois qu'il veut après la guerre est
un moyen de prendre des gages pour
obtenir ça dans la discussion et ça je
me souviens parce que là ça me frappe
parce que c'est à peu près la même chose
le 24 février 2008 après les événements
de belgrade il tient une conférence de
presse en commun avec
madame merkel et lui déclare au monde
entier idée claire de toute façon moi
j'ai exprimé mes buts et c'était
d'autres buts mais que je vais pas
rappeler ici c'est à dire là ma sécurité
par papa d'autant dans les pays dans les
nouveaux pays dans les anciens pays de
l'est et là il dit et si j'arrive pas et
si on ne veut pas me comprendre
j'utiliserai la force armée donc en fait
mon rallye salon on retrouve qu'il avait
déjà employée et en février 2022 comme
vous le savez il arrive à fait des
demandes et les attaques et donc qu on
sait que il va faire et et qu' il va
maintenant qu'il est là il va essayer de
l'avancer de prendre suffisamment de
gages pour obtenir cet événement alors
il ya cet accord militaire présumé en
tout cas avec la chine c'est le new york
times qui le révélait russie qui a
demandé de l'aide économique et
militaire à la chine pour mener sa
guerre pour mener la guerre en ukraine
et contourner les sanctions alors les
russes démentent les chinois n'ont pas
l'air très clair là on apprend parce
qu'effectivement le conseiller à la
maison blanche jay sullivan donc à vue
l'un des os des hauts gradés du parti
communiste aujourd'hui ils disent qu'ils
veulent maintenir des lignes de
communication entre la chine et les
états unis alors est ce que la chine est
un bon allié devenir poutine mais de
toute façon c'est un allié désormais
absolument incontournable il était déjà
allé auparavant ils sont souvent voté
deux concerts au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies contre les autres
désormais la russie au vu de l'ampleur
des sanctions économiques prises à son
encontre
elles sont absolument massive ne peut
que se tourner vers la chine pour pour
essayer de de sauver son économie même
si effectivement elle peut imaginer
continue aussi à commercer avec des pays
comme l'inde qui ont effectivement une
position assez prudente en termes de
sur le dossier ukrainien enfin donc la
chine de toute façon devient absolument
incontournable pour pour vladimir
poutine qui ne peut pas qui ne pourra
pas s'en remettre se remettre de cette
de cette crise économique sans l'aide de
pékin ça c'est sûr mais reconnaissent
avoir l'impression qu'ils sont pas
totalement derrière les russes enfin
qu'ils essayent de joie une carte un peu
d'équilibriste ou pas je crois qu'il
faut essayer de rapprocher enfin de la
perception qu'ont pu avoir moscou et
pékin du comportement occidental depuis
la disparition de l'urss
rappelez-vous disparition de l'urss la
première guerre c'est la guerre du
koweït 120 heures c'est fini bon on
s'imagine occidentaux que la suprématie
militaire occidentale et l on s'institue
gendarme de la planète et on va faire
depuis 1991 à peu près une trentaine
d'interventions extérieures mettez vous
dans la position d'un dirigeant moss de
moscou d'un dirigeant de pékin ils sont
convaincus que de toute façon les
occidentaux ont l'intention de régenter
la totalité de la planète et finalement
quand cette guerre éclate celle ci entre
l'ukraine et la russie on s'aperçoit que
dans les votes de l'onu ya effectivement
une condamnation qui est assez
majoritaire mais quand vous regardez les
pays qui a pris qu'on n'applique rompt
pas les sanctions vous avez beaucoup de
pays notamment africains qui n'ont
aucune intention d'appliquer les
sanctions c'est à dire on s'aperçoit
nous occidentaux que cette espèce du
brise qui nous a occupés depuis 91
équipe faisait qu on intervenait à peu
près partout n'oubliez pas quand même la
libye on a un beau succès là bas et là
tout à coup vous avez des gens qui
motive et ça c'est votre guerre vous
n'êtes plus la communauté internationale
alors justement pour l'accès quid de la
chine est effectivement ils ont passé un
accord militaire ou pas mais alors ça
dépend ce que contient cet accord
militaire si c'est pour fournir des
nourritures pour l'armée russe qui en
manquent cruellement ça c'est pas
possible c'est l'armée russe a toujours
eu des problèmes de logistique déjà en
afghanistan olivier roy constater que
ces armes et si vous voulez de sauf des
pâtes leur camp et qui souvent dit
souvent ils volaient de la farine chez
les afghans bon c'est une armée qui a
toujours eu des problèmes de logistiques
donc annie de menton je confirme il ya
des problèmes de logistique
vraiment très important il ya des scènes
de pillage également en ukraine qui
prouve que c'est une armée mal nourris
mal équipés il fait froid il fait un
froid glacial et l'approvisionnement
n'avait pas été prévu pour une guerre
longue elle avait tout avait été prévu
pour une guerre de trois jours une
semaine or c'est une plaisanterie les
soldats sont très vite dans une
situation de dépendance d'une situer
d'une population locale qu'il aurait
radicalement
ennemis adverse et là aussi ne s'y
attendait pas c'est à dire il faut
qu'ils me pourrait compter sur la chine
vous pensé pour justement l'aider
militairement bah écoutez le problème de
la chine c'est que on attend une réponse
nette elle n'est pas venue c'est à dire
on attend la réponse à la fois
économique et militaire sur un soutien
or là on ne l'a pas parce que la chine
est également site quand même une guerre
politique et la chine est dans une
situation de ce point de vue là
embarrassante et pourquoi à cause de
taiwan à cause de ses propres divisions
internes et ses propres minorités ses
propres séparatistes interne général
jean claude allard est effectivement il
ya un accord militaire entre les deux
pays en plus d'être économique on a vu
qu'avec lens ira mais je pense que pour
moi l'objectif parce que chacun agisse
sans ces gens ces petits politique
poutine les ayant tous perdu il se
replie sur l'ukraine qui paient les pots
cassés de tout ça de ses doutes ses
échecs antérieurs et la chine quel est
l'objectif de la chine 1049
2049 suprématie mondiale absolu
depuis le 6e siècle et sommesous ils
savent que pour gagner une guerre il
vaut mieux ne pas l'engager et à
utiliser d'autres moyens donc je pense
que là ils observent ils ont le cerveau
poutine ils vont pas commettre son
erreur en allant
en allant lancer une guerre et où ils
sont sur leur trajet et ils
agiront pour aider poutine de diverses
façons
parce que la russie n'est pas qu'en
difficulté
militaires d'ici tant qu'elle mxit antec
elle est en difficulté militaires sur
l'ukraine quand même à terme met en
difficulté économique financière et
c'est donc ils aideront mais sans se
dévoiler et de façon à marcher main dans
la main tous les deux vers le la
suprématie donc vous voyez plutôt une
alliance quand même entre eux à la
russie et la chine oui mais brillant
militaire pas ils vont ils vont pas leur
envoyer des soldats et on va pas voir
des soldats chinois en les fans je pense
en
ont vécu alors les chinois ne résonne
plus comme résonner leurs maîtres sont
en dessous on va l'écouter par par la
diplomatie et
poussines antho la ligue anglaise
occident dit on va écouter porte-parole
justement de la diplomatie chinoise
les etats unis ont récemment diffusé une
série de fausses nouvelles visant la
chine sur la question de l'ukraine avec
des intentions malveillantes la position
de la chine sur la question de l'ukraine
a été claire et cohérente
nous avons toujours joué un rôle
constructif en appelant à la paix et aux
négociations la question la plus urgente
à l'heure actuelle est que toutes les
parties fassent preuve de retenue
refroidissant la situation tendue au
lieu de jeter de l'huile sur le feu et
favorise une résolution diplomatique au
lieu d'aggraver la situation suis-je dit
samedi moi ça c'était dans l'action
daphné venant justement à ce qu'est paru
dans le new york times qui disait qu'il
y avait sept accords militaires entre la
chine et la russie dont casse comment
est-ce qu'on vous l'interprétez à
écoutez moi je suis bien incapable de
vous dire si c'était corps existe en
revanche ce qui est certain c'est que je
ne suis pas sûr complètement sûr que là
que le conflit en ukraine face les
affaires de pékin puisque l'écart est
quand même une force économique majeur
et dépend de la bonne santé de
l'économie mondiale
et de fait ça je veux dire la crise en
ukraine va créer des tensions
économiques majeurs sur l'ensemble de
l'économie mondiale et je ne sais pas si
la china a un intérêt à ce que ça se
passe comme ça donc c'est bien la seule
remarque que je puisse faire sur ces
sujets pierre conesa en fait venir
poutine vous l'êtes déjà un peu tourné
le dos à l'europe qu'il appelait
l'europe décadente on voyait d'ailleurs
que le ministre de la défense et regagne
choïgou avait proposé de déplacer la
capitale en sibérie et d'y construire
cinq corps en centres industriels et
scientifiques et ça remonte à un certain
temps il y avait son regard vers l'asie
c'est à dire que la russie est un pays
eurasiatique quand même il faut bien le
reconnaître est la plus grande partie du
pays et quand même de l'autre côté de
l'oural donc si l'invention de l'oural
swiss innovation de géographes c'est
nous qui avons décidé que ça c'était
l'asie et de l'autre côté c'était
l'europe donc que la russie ait des
intérêts asiatique ça personne n'en
doute mais est ce que pour autant la
chine a de bonnes raisons de soutenir
militairement quelque chose qui après
tout a faibli tout la totalité du camp
occidental on est dans une situation
absolument absurde
et encore une fois si vous voulez pour
revenir sur ses dix ans et essayer
encore une fois de raisonner comme peut
raisonner poutine c'est un secrétaire
général du quai d'orsay qui m'a dit ça
on a fait prévaloir la logique
sécuritaire sur la logique diplomatique
c'est à dire que quand gorbatchev 10
sous l'urss on prend des engagements
avec les bons il va disparaître l'homme
du paysage qui fait qu' on va étendre
l'otan de casetas supplémentaires alors
qu'on avait promis que l'otan
n'arriverait pas c'est une prothèse
informel dont elle avait une logique qui
consiste à dire mais tout ça ça fait
rien c'est l'ancien ennemi donc poussé
en plus part des pays satellites qui eux
mêmes avaient été occupées par les
russes et donc on est dans quelque chose
ou si vous voulez en plus de ses
interventions extérieures que l'occident
pour lequel notre l'occident cet automne
endettés quand on est haut à moscou on
commence à avoir des doutes si vous
voulez sur la réelle volonté des
occidentaux d'intégrer la partie euro
asiatique de la russie dans un pacte de
sécurité européenne mais ce que cette
responsabilité les occidentaux vous
décrivez ce qu'elle valait une guerre ah
non non non parce que je vous dis la
solution diplomatique à mon sens aurait
été de faire jouer la responsabilité de
protéger c'est à dire la voyez troupes
russes dans les pays sécessionnistes en
disant nous protégeant nos populations
or là envahi donc il est bien dans une
logique guerrière et cette logique
guerrière c'est peut-être que finalement
il est lui-même est en train de basculer
j'adhère pas l'analyse psychanalytique
mais enfin il ya des moments où les
dictateurs si vous voulez quand ils ont
ils ont du mal à être contredit quoi et
vous dit que finalement ils occidentaux
sont responsables ils ont une part de
responsabilité de l'egypte rania aussi
d'ailleurs parce que finalement ces
régions sécessionnistes vous retrouver
tout à coup avec un pays qui avaient des
frontières administratives et qui
deviennent des frontières politiques et
tout à coup vous avez une partie de ces
gens qui se déplaçaient dans l'ancienne
urss qui avait défait des familles à
droite à gauche etc qui se retrouvent
dans des pays totalement indépendant une
des premières décisions après la révolte
de maidan ça a été faire de l'ukrainien
la seule langue officielle on n'avait
pas de meilleur moyen de se fâcher avec
les 30% de russophones qui avait en
ukraine dont il y avait nous occidentaux
ont des responsabilités dans le sens où
il aurait fallu dire attendez il faut
faire quelque chose pour ces communautés
dispersées les lempira éclatez vous avez
effectivement transnistrie vous avez
dans les états le donbass vous avez à
kaliningrad il reste des séquelles de l'
empire il faut régler tout ça annie de
vente on vous êtes d'accord que ce que
vient de dire pierre connais ça veut
dire poutine a dit que c'était la plus
grande catastrophe tout de même du xxème
siècle au moment de l'effondrement ligne
oui c'est vrai que déjà les vols vont
dire quand j'entends là l'argument de la
langue qui a été un des arguments
disons justifiant du côté occidental le
fait qu'après tout la russie était dans
son bon droit faut peut-être rappeler
tout simplement que l'ukraine est un
pays avec plusieurs langues avec
plusieurs avec des populations diverses
ya les tatars en crimée il ya il ya des
russophones y aller tu sais et que tout
ça ne donne pas des forcément des
disparités politique mais tout
simplement des disparités culturelles
comme on en a dans de pratiquement tous
les pays du monde et qu'à partir du
moment où il y avait
l'émergence d'une volonté
d'européanisation et de démocratisation
du pays je ne vois pas pourquoi elle
n'était pas plus respectable que celle
qui s'est exprimé au moment des
éclatements d'europe centrale de pologne
de hongrie de tchécoslovaquie et c'est
donc là gumende la langue c'est vrai
c'était un argument de l'époque qui a
été beaucoup utilisé mais qui n'existe
pas vraiment dans les fêtes générales
sont claude allaire est ce qu'on peut
dire que cette guerre en ukraine
bouleverse l'ordre mondial
mal bouleverse beaucoup de choses
d'abord elle je crois qu'elle commence à
bouleverser mais là c'est plutôt les
réactions occidentales c'est à dire les
différentes sanctions qui commence à
déséquilibrer le maillage économique
qui avait été mis en place dans le cadre
de la mondialisation des échanges etc
ensuite il y à là les difficultés que
que bon que va voir l'europe avec
l'approvisionnement en énergie pour se
chauffer pour rouler et c'est donc on
voit déjà que quand même il ya il ya un
bouleversement de ce côté là le
l'autre aspect c'est un bouleversement
mais peut-être qu'on ne voit pas bien
c'est enfin deux autres moi je vois ces
jeux les 10 et la chine qui
qui va trouver elle va pas le soutenir
mais elle va profiter de cela pour
continuer et s'appuyer sur cette crise
qui secoue l'occident pour prendre un
peu plus de d'efforts et puis dernier
point me métin c'est une carte qu'on
voit qu'on voit rarement j'ai vu
quelques fois dans les interventions
c'est qui qui montre un peu c'est ce que
disait pis reconnaissance est
effectivement comment le monde voit tout
ça est une petite étude est amené à dire
que
bon c'est vrai ce que ça vaut mais c'est
pour essayer de comprendre et de voir le
petit cygne noir qu'il faut voir et où
le petit fils qu'il faut tirer pour les
jusqu'au bout que pense le monde de
cette guerre
lorsqu'on regarde tous les pays qui ont
se sont abstenus je mets de côté ceux
qui ont appuyé tous les pays quant à
monsieur on arrive à un total de 3,7
milliards d'habitants et les habitants
et les dirigeants ils doivent penser à
peu près ça on a eu ce qui a bouleversé
le monde je crois mais le monde pas le
note le monde s'est tu sais pas ce qu'on
y arrive là dans quelques jours c'est
mars 2003 c'est le la guerre en irak je
crois parce que là ça va être vraiment
ébranlé donc ce n'est pas équivalent la
guerre en irak non
il faut pas faut pas surestimer ou messi
mais ce que je dis c'est
ça n'ébranle pas c'est une guerre entre
la russie
et les etats unis via l'ukraine voilà et
sur le territoire de l'ukraine bon donc
leur est pas leur problème comme daphné
benoit mais nous c'est un danger pour
nous un
bouquin du camp
diront que cette guerre en ukraine a
réveillé les consciences en europe a
provoqué une forme de deux réveils
stratégique que
qui tardait à venir en fait et qui ne se
matérialisait jamais donc cette cette
réaction finalement unanime coordonnée
des européens
donnent à certains l'espoir que l'on
puisse parler plus d'une seule voix et
avoir des ambitions stratégiques
communes en fait on va rester donc sur
cette note d'espoir comme vous dites
merci daphné benoit merci beaucoup
général jean claude allard d'avoir été
avec no mercy a nié daubenton et puis
merci à vous appuyez reconnaît sa merci
à vous tous nous avoir suivis